[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now princess
diana's tragic final hours remain the
subject to much speculation and scandal
even 25 years on from her death channel
4 is the latest to enter the fray with a
four-part documentary investigating
diana death in paris which examines two
police investigations into her passing i
think this have a look at this actually
just start like this
there's so many coincidences so many odd
things that just don't matter 85
of the ordinary people of this country
believe diana was murdered with my son
why would someone want to kill the
princess it's very difficult to defeat a
conspiracy theory
so do these endless inquiries shed
important new light on one of the royal
family's darkest hours or is it finally
time to let the people's princess rest
in peace i'll be joined shortly by try
edward for tom bow with me now is royal
commentator and former spokesman for
mohammed l fired michael cole michael
thank you for joining us tonight what do
you make of this new documentary evening
i didn't watch it i chose not to watch
it
i didn't contribute to it i declined the
invitation
um
i took those decisions because i didn't
think it would elicit anything of any
substance that was new
this morning
a very famous tv household name who was
on television even before i joined
television in 1967.
he said to me nothing new michael
and
i did read
the comments by christopher stevens the
very distinguished
television
reviewer in the daily mail today and he
described the program as trashy
cynical documentary
with sound bites struck strung together
so maybe i made a good decision but the
reason
i found it
and find this all very
very very sad
is that it's it's distressing
i knew
all three people who were killed that
night i i knew diana for 12 years i went
around the world with her
she occasionally phoned me she
occasionally asked advice
we weren't close friends she didn't ask
me out to lunch but we had a good
professional relationship
dodie was always in and out of my office
when he was in london and i knew henry
paul henry paul drove me around in paris
i always got on with him very well
so those were people i liked and admired
and
like mohammed who is still in mourning
after 25 years
i miss them
and
i think it is
a shame if i can put it as lightly as
possible
when this old ground is raked over
for very little purpose on four
consecutive nights on a terrestrial
channel
what is achieved you know jeremy i would
sit here and talk to you
from now until the anniversary next
wednesday
if it achieved anything if it brought
them back and of course it won't do that
so what are we doing here um i'm all in
favor of honest journalistic endeavor
yeah and i do believe that information
will will come out in time i think is
this the right way of doing it i think
if i can jump in i i agree i think i
think many people would quite rightly
say it's distasteful others would say
that maybe there are still questions i'd
like to cross now if i can to fired
biographer tom bower um who joins us now
tom what's your take on this this new
program what's your view sir
well my view is simply this that the
whole controversy was actually created
by mohammed fayed and i must say my old
friend michael cole because the whole
suggestion after the death
that princess diana had been murdered by
prince philip and mi6 in some gigantic
conspiracy in paris was utterly
outrageous by a shameless man called
mohammed fayette and his acolytes and
spokesman i was amongst the very very
first of not the very first person to
arrive at the ritz courtesy of muhammad
fired shortly after diana died and i
spoke to all the hotel staff at the ritz
who had served her and dodi in the hours
before they then
bid them farewell from uh from the
written to their fateful deaths and i
can tell you
that that dash by the car honorary paul
the drunken driver speeding through
paris was approved by mohammed fayed the
staff the ritz told me that they heard
the conversations between dodie and his
father approving that ridiculous
escapade and the idea that anyone could
have plotted to murder diana which is
what mohammed fire perpetrated for 10
years afterwards and why we have these
programs now is absolutely outrageous
there was absolutely no way that anyone
could have plotted
an assassination attempt if they even
had the motive which they didn't and so
it is a torture affair what's awful
about the four-part series now is that
regurgitates all of muhammad fire's
rubbish and not only rubbish but
damaging rubbish it
defames so many good people not least of
all diana because he came up with a
ridiculous idea he had her last words
which was a total fantasy so what's
really shocking about this
series and you know it's just television
so who really cares is that it took 10
years for a proper inquest 10 years
before diana's death was subject to a
judicial inquiry which was outrageous
amount of time and when fire actually
turned up in court with his lawyer
michael mansfield they didn't have a
scintilla of evidence to present which
justified their long campaign that diana
had been the victim with dodie of an
assassination attempt
just regurgitates all that i just want
to bring michael back in not much time
michael your response to what thomas
said briefly sir please
well it wasn't muhammad's fault that it
was a 10-year delay and there were four
uh coroners appointed until they got to
the one who they thought would be
michael michael did mohammed
did mohammed al fired in tom's words
peddle untruths and falsehoods about it
and is the very reason that 25 years
later these programs absolutely made
he he's in he's entitled he's entitled
to his opinion he believes that his son
was killed and he was killed because the
establishment did not want the mother of
the future king to be marrying a muslim
and that's what he believes that he's
entitled to his belief and on the
anniversary he'll go down to dodi's tomb
and he will sit there for a couple of
hours listening to recorded prayers from
the quran and then he'll go back and
he'll have afternoon tea with his
children he is still in mourning he's a
man bereft he lost not just his son but
a very good friend and the allegations
that tom is blithely throwing around i
could answer every single one of them
but we don't have time we don't tom
bower final word from you please briefly
and i mean very briefly sir 20 seconds
well all i can say is he's had 25 years
to prove his conspiracy and i think it
was shameless and cowardly of him to
accuse prince philip of orchestrating
the murder of diana and the rest of the
people in that car it was shocking he
was a drunken driver driving recklessly
drunk and
sadly princess diana wasn't wearing her
tom bauer michael cole thank you very
much indeed i think you two prove i
think the country in the world is
probably still split thank you so much
for watching and that's it for me
you